Freunde herzlich willkommen zu einer
neuen Folge ein Tag persönlicher Koch
und heute ist einer der am meisten
gewünschten Gäste da und ich bin sehr
froh ihn willkommen heißen zu dürfen
Markus rül eine absolute Legende hier
bei mir in der Küche ja vielen Dank für
die Einladung schön dass du hier bist
wirklich ich freue mich sehr es ist was
besonderes für dich Kochen zu dürfen
weil ich glaube du bist ein bisschen
bekannt für Dinge die Du gegessen hast
die vielleicht auch ein bisschen anders
sind als was ich hier in meiner Küche
veranstalte bin jetzt nicht der gumme ne
also ich habe viele Dinge essen Biss in
meiner Karriere die nicht so lecker
waren deswegen vielen Dank dass ich
heute so ein köstliches Menü hoffentlich
genießen darf bei unbedingt du kriegst
natürlich Frühstück Mittag Abendessen du
musst ein bisschen deine Gourmet Skills
heute einsetzen weil du wirst jedes
Essen bewerten müssen und zwar von ull
bis ze bin ich sehr gespannt bin ich
sehr gespannt was Du sagen wirst erstmal
eine Auswahl wir machen zum Frühstück
Steak und eggs mit frühstückskartoffeln
ich habe hier zwei schöne Steaks
eingekauft Steak gab es wahrscheinlich
viel bei dir aber wahrscheinlich weniger
so fettiges ne ja es g dann schon erst
Filet ne oder oder halt auch viel
lieberniier also sehr magis
Fleisch ich tendi dann eher so bisschen
zu da bist du der Feinschmecker wir
haben nämlich einmal ein US Beef das ist
re CDE ne ripy und hier drüben haben wir
ein wagio Rumsteak das heißt Rumsteak ja
dann nehmen wir doch das Rumsteak da
wird sich was gegönnt ich habe eine
Frage an dich Markus ich habe dich im
Vorfeld gefragt müssen wir ein
Proteinbedarf Decken und du hast gesagt
Koch einfach Hauptsache ist gesund daher
habe ich mich gefragt muss es nicht mehr
wirk nur noch schmecken es muss auch
schmecken nicht n wirk heute haben
bisschen rumgedreht ne muss schck mir
schon ein bisschen mehr rausgekommen ich
bin auch jetzt ein genieser ne also es
ist jetzt glaub 20 Jahre lang mit tonfis
Shake und reiwael mit Protein das
Eiweißpulver war eher so Fenster Kit ne
das war so altes Milchprotein angerührt
fest ne hast jghurt oder quar gehabt das
war ja gar nicht zurückegang Geber also
hast du früher und so bin ich ja groß
geworden alles über die Ernährung
Funktionalität reingekriegt und dann kam
es Thema und das ist auch das
nachhaltigste eigentlich ne dass man
schaut dass man das meiste schon über
Ernährung deckt Nahrung sollte immer an
erster Stelle sein ja gutes Stichwort
Nahrung ich glaube ich Zauber hier mal
ein bisschen du kannst dich wirklich wie
zu Hause fühlen wenn du magst machst dir
gemütlich kannst natürlich auch ein
bisschen zugucken worauf du Lust hast
wirklich ich komme ab und zu und schau
mal über die Schulter ich find das Spann
machen wir so machen es geht auf jeden
Fall flott also gleich gibt's was zu
essen starten wir mit dem Steak und das
ist wirklich eine Schönheit ich meine
ich lasse mich nicht lumpen ne wenn der
Magus zu Besuch ist dann wird gezaubert
dann wird auch gut eingekauft wir haben
ein australisches wagu 9 plus
Marmorierung es ist wirklich wunderschön
ich nehme das fettstück ab und lass das
ein wenig in meiner Pfanne aus S dass
wir dann quasi das Steak im Eigenfett
braten können das ist einfach schön
Pfanne ist heiß wir machen das in ein
richtig dicken gusseisernen Pfanne guck
mal was da wirklich direkt an Fett
rauskommt ich meine es ist ja auch
einfach puges fett aber trotzdem einfach
schön anzusehen wir werden das scharf
anbraten von beiden Seiten und dann kurz
während der restlichen Vorbereitung im
Ofen ruhen lassen ich salze schon mal
mein Steak von allen Seiten ordentlich
geht dann noch mal der Griff wieder in
die blockbox ne übrigens das letzte
blockprodukt was noch erhältlich ist
Brett und scraper sind ausverkauft wir
werden natürlich nachproduzieren aber
wenn ihr Lust habt auf so eine Box wisst
ihr ja wo die zu finden sind ne blog.
Shop normalerweise ihr wisst es bei
Steak immer gerne noch mit
Knoblauchpulver und so spieleereinen
unterwegs hier tut es einfach nur Salz
ich mache nicht mal Pfeffer das Fleisch
ist übrigens schon eine ganze Stunde
draußen ich habe das ein bisschen auf
Temperatur kommen lassen aber ich glaube
für das was wir hier gerade machen so
ein schönes breakfast Steak ist das
perfekt okay Scheiße wir haben gerade
Markus gefragt wie er gerne das Steak
hätte und der hat gesagt well done
Eintrag persönlicher
Kopf keine Fragen keine Fragen stellen
Steak in die Pfanne hinein vom Körper
weg ordentlich andrücken und jetzt
einfach ruhen lassen hier drüben habe
ich übrigens was vorbereitet ich habe
eine Kartoffel einfach wie folgt
geschnitten ich zeig's euch einmal weil
es ist echt eine geile Sache fürs
Frühstück einfach Kartoffel schneiden in
Scheiben dann so Stifte rausschneiden
und Würfel und diese Würfel habe ich
jetzt vorgekocht damit es gleich ein
bisschen schneller geht ihr könnt diese
Würfel später aber auch einfach in eine
Pfanne geben 20 Minuten lang
durchschwenken s dass sie gleichmäßig
erhitzt werden und dann habt ihr
perfekte frühstückskartoffeln und das
ist wirklich geil weil in Deutschland
isst man das kaum für unser Steak mache
ich eine kleine chimiuri Soße das heißt
Pet jede Menge petasilie einfach ganz
fein haacken dazu ein bisschen Knoblauch
Chili das machen
wir gucken wir uns mal unser Steak an
das ist eine Kruste und bisschen Fett
wieder in die Mitte spielen
platzieren wunderschön die wird aber
noch krasser ich flipp das noch ein paar
mal hinten raus das wird richtig geil
leg noch was auf Steak drauf so dass es
noch besseren Kontakt bekommt und eine
gleichmäßige Krust erhält jetzt
geschnitten die gebe ich mir hier einmal
in Schüssel hinein
[Musik]
bisschen Chili Markus mag es nicht zu
gern
scharf das ist wirklich eine Kruste wie
sie im Buche steht zu unserem chimiuri
gebe ich jetzt noch ein bisschen
Weißweinessig und natürlich jede Menge
Olivenöl jetzt nicht perfekt für die
gains aber man muss ja auch nicht so
viel chimuri nehmen einfach so ein
kleiner Teelöffel macht jedes Steak
besser muss schmecke mittlerweile wir
vernachlässigen natürlich nicht die se
guck mal wie wunderschön das in diesem
ausgelassenen Fett blubbert und das
Schöne ist halt wirklich dadurch dass
Markus well done bestellt hat können wir
halt die beste Kruste ever Zen ne das
ist wie ein chit so Markus wir sind
schon in den letzten Schritten hier drin
habe ich die Kartoffeln was wäre so ein
klassisches Frühstück für dich früher
gewesen relativ banal haflocken Milch
und Eiweißpulver jeden Morgen eigentlich
schon ja wie lang glaub 10 Jahre lang W
glaube ich nichts für mich aber luus ein
Luxus Artikel war schon mal paar
Rühreier oder so war dann einfach an der
haflock mit ne das waren 30 Sekunden war
du fertig ja ich stell mir das oh ich
habe ja ganz die Gewürze vergessen vor
lauter quatschen wir haben hauen
natürlich an die Kartoffeln auch noch
ein bisschen cayenpfeffer du magst es
nicht so gerne scharf ne nicht ganz so
scharf nee da bin ich auch wieder raus
ja Gewürze sind ja okay aber wenn du
dann fast denkst du verlierst das
Bewusstsein ja gutes Essen gesundes
Essen gute milchkost gute Zutaten da
geht z Körper gut ich denke mal wenn du
was gegessen hast was schmeckt und dir
geht's gut danach dann war es auch
sauber ja absolut und alles andere
ist echt sau lecker aus jetzt scheiße K
jetzt echt Hunger oh ich richte das
ganze jetzt schön an und dann sehen wir
uns gleich am Tisch
[Musik]
wieder so Markus das ist Zeit für
Frühstück geil Hammer ich hoffe der
Garpunkt passt ja ist gut ja lecker also
vielen Dank erstmal vi also erstmal zu
verstehen was alles ist Kartoffeln
spegelei rumsck s mal als Banause und
das ist so ein gräuerpesto oder das ist
ein chimiuri also im Prinzip bisschen Öl
frische Kräuter ist noch ein bisschen
dimte drin bisschen Knoblauch ganz
bisschen Chili weil ich wollte dich
nicht nicht wieder verbrennen das ist es
im Prinzip Hammer super dann sehen wir
uns gleich wieder wenn der Teller
hoffentlich aufgegessen ist was soll ich
sagen ne Max wie man meinem Teller schon
sieht der ist ausgelckt ne sensationell
also Kompliment Kompliment ohne Scheiß
ist eins der besten Steaks das gegessen
hab und jetzt nicht nur weil die Kamera
läuft oder weil weil du jetzt neben mir
sitzt es ist sensationell gewesen
Kompliment aus höchsten und ich habe
schon das eine andere Stück Fleisch
gegessen be Leben glaub ich Hammer wie
sagt mal so beim Promidinner meine
Tendenz ist 11 von ze 11 von
ze ja 11 Frühstück die schmeckt mir fast
noch besser als ich bin Weltrekord
gesprungenama richtig gut man hat echt
gemerkt die hat geschmeckt und das macht
mir Freude so hab ich am liebsten wo man
auch weiß es mundet es schmeckt ich war
auch sehr zufrieden also das könn ich
auch jeden Morgen Essen vielleicht
bisschen mächtig für jeden Morgen aber
auf so ein Sonnentag ist das glaube ich
der perfekte Start in so ein englisches
Frühstück ne deftig ich bin der so ein
Mensch der auch gerne mal gern deftig
ist auch morgens ne nach 20 jahrl mit
Milch also war mir Genuss vielen Dank da
dafür sehr gerne es wird ein bisschen
leichter zum Mittagessen ich würde sagen
wir begeben uns in die Küche bereiten
ein bisschen was vor und dann können wir
gleich Markus wieder begrüßen denn das
wird wirklich wirklich lecker ich habe
ja ein wunderschönes Thunfisch Steak
welches wir zu Tatar verarbeiten werden
deshalb schneide ich es in kleine Würfel
ungefähr 1 cm groß und das ist aber
nicht alles wir haben ja ein
wunderschönes Sauerteigbrot das werde
ich in Scheiben anrösten und dann
Schichte ich das Tatar abwechselnd mit
Avocado also Avocado Thunfisch Tatar mit
Sauerteigbrot einfach schnell und vor
allem lecker so ich schneide mir hier
raus so Scheibchen auch hier ne ganz
wichtig wie immer der Einkauf beim
Frühstück war es der Einkauf hier ist es
der Einkauf man muss einfach gucken dass
man vernünftige Sachen kauft sonst sonst
bringt es nichts also gerade wenn man so
mit Fisch mit Fleisch arbeitet muss halt
die Stimmen und dieses Thunfisch Steak
ist Sashimi Qualität das heißt man kann
es roh essen sollte man auch roh essen
können weil beim Tatar bleibt es auch
roh ich glaube das ist auf jeden Fall
eine genussvollere Art Thunfisch zu
konsumieren als damals in den thunfishch
Shakes lieber Thunfisch Steaks als
Thunfisch Shakes ist das eine These der
Markus zustimmen würde ich werde ihn
gleich fragen er ist gerade bei World
Wohnzimmer ALR dann schneide ich daraus
einfach
Streifen die Streifen dann wiederum sind
thunfischnudeln quasi die schneide ich
dann in Würfel und der ist so zart dass
er schon ein bisschen auseinander fällt
aber so so darf es sein so soll es sein
so habe ich es mir gewünscht alles passt
perfekt zusammen wie geht es noch mal
weiter das Lied so soll es sein so soll
es bleiben so hab ich es mir gewünscht
diger das ist wirklich schlimm ich bin
alt irgendwie sowas diger keine Ahnung
war ein radiolied als ich jung
war was sagen jetzt alte Menschen der
Thunfisch ist in Würfel geschnitten das
heißt wir können jetzt ein paar Zutaten
hinzugeben z.B helle
Sojasoße Sesamöl ganz wichtig für diesen
klassischen asiatischen Taste etwas
Reisessig dann rühren wir schon mal ein
bisschen durch damit die Säure nicht
gart sage ich jetzt einfach ich habe
gerade Angst dass das passiert ein
Spritzer Limette hier wieder schön
durchrühren und das toppen wir am Ende
mit ein paar Sesamkörnern ich gebe jetzt
aber schon ein paar dazu s dazwischen
sind sieht einfach schön aus und
wirklich wie sich das jetzt gerade
geruchlich verändert hat und was das
auch mit dem Geschmack macht weil so ein
Thunfisch Tatar ist ja nicht so
geschmacksintensiv aber jetzt riech mal
bitte boah hast du wirklich die ganze
Breitseite richtig geil schöner
asiatischer Touch normalerweise kann man
da jetzt noch Koriander dazu machen mag
der Markus nicht so gerne aber ein
bisschen Chili kommt noch dazu bisschen
durchhacken nehme ich da so eine
Messerspitze von mit rein nicht dass
Markus wieder das gleiche Erlebnis hat
ganz fein haacken daavon ein bisschen
was dazu eine Zutat fehlt noch ein wenig
frisch geriebener ingwa und dann ist das
das leckerste und schnellste was man mit
einem Thunfisch anfangen kann geil
richtig geil das schmeckt richtig gut
little bit
Sil sieht das nicht einfach schön aus
diese einzelnen Würfel die Farbe die
Sesamkörner einmal durchrühren und das
lassen wir jetzt auch schön kühl
gestellt treue Zuschauer erkennen was
das hier ist das ist mein absolutes
Lieblingsbrot ein Sauerteigbrot von dem
Bäcker hier um die Ecke wirklich könnte
ich zu allem Essen es ist knusprig es
ist saftig es hat so ein richtig schönen
entwickelten sauerteiggeschmack und die
perfekte Begleitung zu unserem tatan ich
schneid ein paar Scheiben und röste
[Musik]
die schneiden wir jetzt ein paar
avokadowürfel und sie hat wirklich eine
rige weiche Textur hier sind unsere
avocadowürfel an die gebe ich ein wenig
Salz dann kommt noch ein Spritzer
Limette dazu wenn die gesizen ist gebe
ich dir eine Schüssel ungefähr so viel
wie unser tunfischatter perfekt behutsam
ein wenig durchrühren s dass wir die
einzelnen Würfel
haben dann gehen wir ein bisschen
Limette dazu zack zack dann rösten wir
das Brot zu Ende und dann können wir
auch schon
[Musik]
anrichten
ü gemacht ne ja sehr gut und
funktioniert guck
malent ja wir haben ein Avocado Tuna Tat
mit Gerö sauerte Avocado ich liebe
Avocado ja si mal sehr gut der Hunger
ist zu
groß das dachte ich mir auch ist SAS
schönes nachdem wir schon es Frühstück
hatten einfach so auf dem Sauerteigbrot
mach sie dir immer so ein schönen Happen
fertig schade dass es nicht schmecken
könnt ne muss so geschmackstv ne ich
glaube das sollten wir uns jetzt
genehmigen und uns dann gleich zur
Bewertung Wiedersehen mit dir gibt's nur
leere Teller Markus ja ich weiß ich bin
eine gute Hausfrau ne macht die Teller
leer morgen scheint die Sonne hier in
der Ecke also Teller leer war sehr sehr
lecker die Kombination zwischen tonfisch
Tatar dem Avocado schön geschnitten
lecker gewürzt oder paar limoncheibe od
das Brot also ich bin sprachlos freut
mich sehr kannst fter
kommen du kannst du kannst mich gerne
anrufen ich komm vor allem auf das ist
gutin wirklich also ich bin ohne W ja
ich war ja verhinter bei 11 ne jetzt
muss ich auf 12 gehen weil mehr geht
nicht ja also wirklich h also es macht
richtig Spaß ich glaube wir machen jetzt
noch ein Abendessen lassen da noch mal
richtig krachen dann gucken wir ob die
13 drin ist sch also ich glaub da kann
man schwer dran anknüpfen aber ich geb
mir natürlich Mühe zum Abendessen geen
wir uns noch mal richtig Mühe denn wir
machen etwas ganz Besonderes wir machen
ein ganzes Hähnchen mit Ofengemüse
deshalb kümmerere ich mich erstmal ums
Ofengemüse ich habe ein Backblech das
werde ich gleich einfach drunterlegen
wenn ich das Hähnchen in den Ofen
schiebe und darauf schnibbel ich einfach
ganz grob ein bisschen Gemüse ich habe
ein paar Pastinaken das ist so ein Ding
das erledigt sich quasi von selbst paar
große Stücke Karotten so und so laden
wir einfach das ganze Backblech voll ich
vitel noch ein paar drillingskartoffeln
paar Gewürze dazu ein bisschen Zwiebel
ordentlich Knoblauch und dann kann es
nur gut werden wenn das gleich unter dem
Saft vom Hähnchen gart jetzt gebe ich
noch ein zwei Stifte Rosmarin dazu es
sieht schon wundersch schön aus und es
kann auch nur gut schmecken um den
Anfang bisschen zu unterstützen wo noch
kein Fett vom Hähnchen tropft ein wenig
Olivenöl eine Prise Salz etwas Pfeffer
und dann Mengen wir das ein wenig durch
Ofengemüse ist eh einfach OP man kann
einfach irgendwas im Ofen machen packt
ein bisschen Gemüse dazu und hat eine
fertige Beilage das ist einfach
wunderschön und es ist einfach frisch
gekocht jetzt habe ich was vorbereitet
und zwar seht ihr hier ein
maisishähnchen dass ich schon gestern
vorbereitet habe ihr seht es liegt flach
denn wir haben die Wirbelsäule entfernt
so dass man es flach ausbreiten kann das
hat einen ganz bestimmten Grund so kann
die Hitze gleichmäßig die Schenkel und
die brustgarn wenn du das Hähnchen sonst
kompakt zusammen hast funktioniert das
nicht so gut und falls ihr euch fragt
was das hier oben drauf ist das sind
Backpulver und Salz die ein bisschen die
Feuchtigkeit nach oben holen sass es
extra knusprig wird eine weitere Sache
hilft dabei dass es extra knusprig wird
dass hier das Mayonnaise das Rezept ist
von Kenji Lopez old eine meiner
absoluten Favorites wir machen folgendes
ich schnbbel ein bisschen seibei dann
nehme ich mir Rosmarin ziehe den einfach
hier ab wir machen nämlich jetzt so eine
kleine kräutermayonnaise und falls ihr
euch gerade fragt was geht jetzt ab was
macht er hier hat jemand gemacht der
viel schlauer ist als ich denn dadurch
dass wir gleich eine Schicht Mayonnaise
auf das Hähnchen auftragen frittiert es
quasi in dieser Mayonnaise die ja nichts
anderes ist als Fett und Ei und dadurch
dass da Ei dabei ist hält das an Ort und
Stelle wenn man Butter drauf macht läuft
sie runter und so sollte es perfekt
rundum Frittieren einmal durchhacken und
dann geen wir das in die Mayo hinein mit
einem kleinen Löffel chimiuri habe ich
mir jetzt einfach überlegt wird schon
klappen jetzt ordentlich durchrühren und
fertig ist unsere kräutermo die ich
jetzt hier einfach auf unser Hühnchen
drauf geh packe ich mir ein Handschuh
und dann gibt's eine ordentliche Massage
einfach die Mayonnaise an allen Stellen
auftragen nicht zu dünn nicht zu dick
vor allem gleichmäßig beginnen wir indem
wir unser Ofengemüse in den Ofen geben
das kommt schon mal rein unser Hähnchen
dass wir einfach oben drüber setzen und
so schließen wir jetzt die Ofentür für
mindestens 30 Minuten bei 230°
oberunterhitze kümmern wir uns jetzt um
unsere Soße wir schneiden einfach so z D
cm Stücke und die rösten wir gleich so
richtig kräftig an dafür gebe ich ein
wenig Olivenöl
Rin und jetzt keine falsche Scheu gucken
dass es einmal ordentlich Kontaktfläche
hat und jetzt einfach auch mal ein
bisschen Geduld haben so der Abzug ist
euer Freund Leute ich muss ein bisschen
lauter reden aber guckt euch mal die
Farbe an die wir da schon dran bekommen
haben von allen Seiten rösten wir das
ein bisschen an denn da steckt richtig
Geschmack drin so jetzt geben wir ein
bisschen Gemüse dazu da kann man nehmen
was man da hat Sellerie whatever ich
habe Karotten Pastinaken und Schalotten
geben wir mit dazu und auch die werden
ordentlich angeröstet so wenn das ein
bisschen gebraten hat wenn sich
ordentlich röcharum am Boden gebildet
haben können wir mit einem guten Stuck
Weißwein ablöschen ich muss h drüben
sprechen so deglasieren wir die Pfanne
und die Röstaromen lösen sich quasi in
die Flüssigkeit auf man sieht es richtig
schön der Boden ist jetzt wieder
komplett sauber so wenn es wieder leicht
beginnt zu zffchen schütten wir ein
bisschen Brühe drauf das kühlt das Ganze
ab und wenn das beginintnt zu köcheln
dann können wir es ein wenig
runterstellen und zu guter Letzt gebe
ich noch ein paar Kräuter dazu die
einfach noch mehr Geschmack in die Soße
abgeben so lassen wir das jetzt köcheln
dann seihen wir es ab und binden die
Soße ein wenig an kommt mal her leute
schaut euch das bitte mal an das
Hühnchen ist jetzt fertig hat eine
wunderschöne Farbe bekommen ohne Witz es
ist einfach nur perfekt es hat eine
Kruste die wirklich unvergleichlich ist
erhalten Sie köchelt förmlich und hier
unten drunter sieht man wirklich da ist
Flüssigkeit da ist juice was willst du
mehr ganz ehrlich was willst du mehr die
Soße ist auch schon fertig und wir
können
[Musik]
Anrichten das ist noch mal eine
ordentlich Portion zum
abschlusswibel
guten Appetit ein ganzes Hähnchen aus
dem Ofen jeder kriegt eine Brust jeder
kriegt einen Schenkel ich habe die Soße
separat gemacht dass du so ein bisschen
so die Knusprigkeit noch hast vom
Hähnchen die Zuschauer wundern sich
vielleicht ist es noch ein Salat
aufgetaucht weil wir haben gesagt noch
was Frisches dazu kann auch nicht
schaden fätsalat wrett Charlotten ist
nichts besonderes jetzt erstmal Salat ne
guck mal wer das gedacht da liegt ein
Hähnchen auf dem Teller und Markus rül
ist zuerst Salat erstmal Salat ja also
hamersalat kan Z Veganer W hier ich bin
jetzt mal pa Nause bitte komm dir gleich
fühlst du dich nicht so allein guck dir
mal den Glanz vom Hähnchen an ja und das
schmeckt noch besser wie es aussieht
also das schst du troffen glaube ich
heute ich dachte mir auch dass es dass
es lecker wird aber ein Hähnchen so
zuzubereiten ist wirklich die einzig
richtige Art und Weise oh mein Gott das
sieht sehr schön aus ein letztes Mal ist
er leer der Teller oder aber es war
nicht so leicht das war eine große
Portion auch für Markus Rühl oder muss
ich ganz ehrlich zugeben das war eine
sehr sehr leckere aber sehr ausreichende
Portion aber trotzdem ihr seht der
Teller ist leer und es hat her voren
gemundet also ich bin sehr glücklich
mein Bauch ist happy vielen Dank für das
tolle Essen unbedingt es waren jetzt
drei Mahlzeiten die haben sich
gegenseitig immer mehr übertroffen bin
ich ganz ehrlich super angefangen und
das Highlight war natürlich jetzt Max
also Punktezahl was soll ich dir sagen
ich du sagst du sagst ze ist es
Highlight ja ich war bei 12 jetzt bin
ich bei 20 also ohne Scheiß 20 der all
record die höchste Punktzahl aller Zeit
hat sich ja immer mehr aufgepauscht
irand mus du multiplizieren nicht
addieren und das ist mehr geht wirklich
kann ich nur Danke sagen für die lieben
Worte ja war ein geiles Video ich hoffe
euch hat es gefallen lasst gerne ein
Like und ein Kommentar da wenn es ist
wenn es so war schaut bei Markus vorbei
wir sehen uns beim nächsten Video wieder
bis dahin ciao ciao liebe Grüße ciao